hey 42 here Napoleon bonapart is one of
the most influential people in the
history of mankind and you don't have to
take my word for it that was the
conclusion reached in the 2013 book
who's bigger which ranked historical
figures in order of their significance
of 100 billion or so members of our
species that have lived and died to date
Napoleon bonapart came second the French
meet in a religious sandwich between
Jesus Christ and the prophet
Muhammad Napoleon is probably most
famous today for his Brilliance as a
general he led his troops in more than
80 battles winning a staggering 90% of
them nov General in recorded history can
even come close to matching those
numbers he practically invented Modern
Warfare and it's no exaggeration to say
that he is probably the greatest
military genius that's ever
lived but his story is a surprising one
for example did you know that the most
famous Frenchman in history didn't even
speak French until he was 10 years old
or that he very nearly gave up on his
military career to write Saucy romance
novels neither did I and there's more
when he wasn't terrorizing the rest of
Europe Napoleon found the time to broker
the biggest deal in the history of real
estate accidentally helped mankind to
translate Egyptian hieroglyphics and put
together legal economic and educational
reforms that quite literally changed the
world oh and one of his distant
relatives was the voice actor who played
Chef Louie in The Little
Mermaid I think that might actually be
my favorite random interesting fact of
all time there's really no other way of
saying it Napoleon bonapart lived one of
the most incredible lives in history
here's how it went by the way if like me
you also think it's about time to do
something to protect our planet's
ecosystems stick around until the end
there I have an inspiring recommendation
from my friends at Planet wild an
environmental Protection Organization
that you won't want to miss Napoleon was
born on the French island of Corsica on
the 15th of August
1769 well I say French island just three
months before Napoleon executed his
first successful military Advance
through his mother's birth canal Cora
had been an independent sovereign state
the French invaded after buying it from
former owners the Republic of genua and
most of the locals understandably
weren't too happy about
it despite being six months pregnant
Napoleon's mother along with his father
joined the Coran resistance fighting a
bloody gorilla war against the French
Invaders most historians consider the
siege of tulon to be his first major
battle but I beg to differ baby bonapart
took part in his first war as a fetus it
ended up being one of the few losses of
his career France was the richest most
populous country in Europe at the time
and the corsicans Never really stood a
chance but anti- Fringe sentiment
remained High amongst much of the
population including the young Napoleon
which is why he wasn't best pleased when
at the age of nine his father shipped
him off to a fancy French boarding
school on the
mainland it was a big change for
Napoleon and he absolutely hated it
technically speaking he was as French as
a cbear baguette but he couldn't have
felt more foreign which isn't all that
surprising really considering he didn't
actually speak French only corsac and
Italian he picked up the lingo pretty
quickly but he would never lose his
corsac accent even as an
adult a year later he earned a
scholarship to the prestigious Military
Academy at Brien leau and he despised it
every bit as much as he hated boarding
school his classmates were all the sons
of French aristocracy and whilst
Napolean himself descended from minor
Italian nobility his family were by no
means rich
he graduated military school at the age
of 16 and got his first Army posting as
a second lieutenant in an artillery unit
he learned fast and before long he was
one of the most capable soldiers in his
unit but the promotions he felt he
deserved never came French society at
the time was based on a strict hierarchy
first came the church then the
aristocracy and finally the
commoners Napoleon was technically part
of the aristocracy but if no men were
supermarkets he would have been Asda and
if you wanted to reach the most senior
positions in the Army you had to be
wait no matter how hard he worked or how
good he was Napoleon would always be
held back by his Heritage or at least
that's what he fought but then the
French Revolution happened the social
hierarchy that had governed French
society for centuries was torn to shreds
as revolutionists overthrew the monarchy
and stripped the aristocracy of their
privileges King Louis the 16th and his
wife Marian toinette were given the
guillotine
treatment and France was declared a
republic ruled by politicians elected by
popular
vote the French Revolution wasn't
televised obviously but word still got
around and when the rest of Europe heard
what was going on in France they weren't
best pleased in fact they were few
curious most countries in Europe had
monarchies and aristocracies of their
own and the revolutionary ideas coming
out of France posed an existential
threat to all of them and so Europe's
venerable leaders decided to resolve
their ideological differences like the
gentlemen of culture they were just
kidding they went to war Great Britain
the Holy Roman Empire Portugal Prussia
Sardinia Spain and several other
countries formed the mother of all tag
teams to lay the absolute SmackDown on
revolutionary France the war of the
first Coalition had
begun for your average Frenchman having
half a continent declare war on you was
probably quite scary but for Napoleon
bonapart it was like Christmas had come
early there was suddenly a massive
demand for capable military men to lead
France's Army against her countless
enemies and you didn't even need to have
stepped foot in a waitrose to get the
job
his first taste of leadership came in
1793 after royalist Rebels supported by
British and Spanish ships seized the
port of the city of
tulong Napoleon came up with a bold plan
to liberate the City by storming a
Hilltop fort in the middle of the night
and turning its cannons on the Coalition
ships blockading the harbor he led the
attack himself taking a bayonet to defy
in the process but the plan worked a
treat a
24-year-old Napoleon had just won his
first significant battle and the world
got its first glimpse of what the
greatest military genius in history was
capable of Napoleon was promoted to
Brigadier General but just when it
seemed his Grand military Ambitions
would finally be fulfilled they were
dealt a significant
blow his first posting was to put down a
royalist rebellion in Western France but
he considered the task to be beneath his
considerable talents and so he did what
any grown man does when faced with a job
he doesn't really fancy he pulls a Sicky
he was so miffed he even attempted a
wild career change writing a saucy
romance novel where the leading man bore
a striking resemblance to Napoleon
himself he was removed from the French
Army's list of available generals and
for a while it looked like his military
career was over before it had really
begun but that changed in October
1795 when 25,000 soldiers launched a
devastating assault on the City of Paris
these soldiers weren't British and they
weren't Portuguese or Prussian either in
fact the Army didn't belong to any of
the Coalition Nations it was French a
huge royalist Uprising intent on
overthrowing the new government and
reinstating the monarchy if it was
successful the French Revolution was
over with only 5,000 Republican soldiers
in the capital at the time the Defenders
were outnumbered five to one and to make
matters worse there wasn't really anyone
to lead them almost all of the senior
officers in the Army had been members of
the aristocracy and many had fled at the
outbreak of the Revolution but as luck
would have it a promising romance
novelist by the name of Napoleon
bonapart happens to be in Paris at the
time he was asked to join the fight and
he agreed on just one condition that he
be given
command he had fewer than 24 hours to
make his preparations but he used to
time wisely concentrating his men at
choke points in the streets around the
t's Palace seat of the new government
and setting up artillery at strategic
points to create kill
zones the royalists launched their first
assault in the early hours of the
morning of the 5th of October and when
the fighting began Napoleon was right
there in the thick of it staying on the
front lines even after his horse was
shot out from underneath him his hastily
assembled defensive positions were so
effective they not only held he lost
fewer than 100 men as he convincingly
defeated the significantly larger
royalist
Army and just like that he went from
angsty romance offer to savior of the
Revolution still only 26 at the time
Napoleon was promoted to General
in-chief and given full command of the
French army in Northern Italy
he got his first look at his brand new
Army in March
1796 but what he saw wasn't exactly
encouraging of the 13 field armies under
French control at the time napoleons was
by far the weakest his soldiers were
malnourished poorly equipped and most of
them hadn't been paid for months morale
was so low that several units had
mutinied and many more were on the brink
of 63,000 troops at Napoleon's disposal
just 38,000 were considered battle ready
and to make matters worse Northern Italy
was a coalition stronghold with Austrian
and Sardinian armies swarming all over
the
place despite the condition of his
troops Napoleon surprised Everyone by
going on the offensive within just two
weeks of arriving in Italy and
apparently a fortnite was all he'd
needed to turn his ragtag band of
mutinous mercenaries into a lethal
fighting machine because in his very
first battle as a fully fledged General
he absolutely obliterated a joint
Sardinian Austrian Army 30 Mi west of
genua at the end of the battle 3 and a
half thousand enemy soldiers were dead
Napoleon had lost just 200
men over the course of the next 12
months commanding what was supposed to
be France's weakest field Army against
more experienced Generals in a territory
where he was heavily outnumbered
Napoleon went on an absolute Rampage
winning 19 of his 21
battles the Coalition forces were so
comprehensively beaten by the rookie
General that they were forced to sue for
peace relinquishing control of Northern
Italy to the French Napoleon had ended
the war of the first Coalition pretty
much on his own with all of the Allies
barring Britain throwing in in the towel
by signing the Treaty of Campo foro that
left the two biggest bullies in the
European playground doing what they do
best calling each other rude names
across the English Channel after one
particularly spicy insults that probably
involved frog legs or something the
French briefly considered a full-on
Invasion led by Napoleon but after
months of planning he concluded that he
didn't have enough ships to tackle the
might of the royal Navy at least not yet
that left him with two choices sit
around being all peaceful for a bit or
find someone else to beat up no prizes
for guessing which he went for at first
his choice of a Target Egypt seemed a
little bit random but Napoleon had a
cunning plan at the turn of the 19th
century Britain was one of the
wealthiest countries on Earth and the
large proportion of that cash money came
from British India British trade ships
made the journey to the subcontinent by
sailing around Africa but communication
between the two Nations usually went
through the Middle East for the simple
reason that it was much
faster invading Egypt was a double
whammy Not only would it disrupt
Britain's links to India it would also
provide a staging point for a future
French invasion as far as plans go it
was a bold one but when Napoleon laid it
out before the French government they
agreed to it so quickly it was almost a
little bit
suspicious you see by this point
Napoleon wasn't just France's deadliest
weapon he was also a national hero and
that was a potentially dangerous
combination rumors were beginning to
spread that sooner or later the young
General would make a bid for power by
shipping him off to Egypt for a year or
two the Republican government was
protecting itself as much as damaging
the British on the 19th of May 1798
Napoleon Egyptian Invasion force of some
40,000 Men set sail for North Africa but
it wasn't just soldiers on board those
ships Napoleon had recently been elected
to the French Academy of Sciences and he
realized that this new role gave him the
opportunity to spin his invasion not as
a war of expansion but as an expedition
of
Enlightenment to make it all seem a bit
more legit he brought close to 200
scientists along for the ride more on
what they got up to in a minute the
fleet landed in Egypt on the 1st of July
1798 quickly capturing the city of
Alexandria from there Napoleon marched
about half of his Force across the
desert to Cairo where he found 40,000
angry otoman soldiers waiting for him as
Stones throw away from the
Pyramids by this point everyone in
Europe had figured out that Napoleon was
basically a cheat code and wasn't to be
messed with but this wasn't Europe the
osaman soldiers had no idea who they
were dealing with and since they
outnumbered their enemies 2 to one they
quite understandably expected an easy
Victory and that's exactly what it was
just not for them in fact the battle of
the pyramids was one of the most
one-sided engagements in the history of
warfare the ottoman Cavalry was
legendary and faced with wave after wave
of charges Napoleon casually came up
with a brand new tactic arranging his
Riflemen into enormous rectangles so
that they couldn't be flanked
at the cost of just
289 French lives more than
10,000 ottoman soldiers were killed and
Egypt belonged to France not that
Napoleon got to enjoy his latest
absolutely ridiculous victory for long
because it turned out that the British
had known about his little Invasion
force all along they just weren't sure
exactly when Napoleon was planning to
invade so they dispatched rear Admiral
Horatio Nelson to go and find
out heading a large Fleet of his own
Nelson had spent the previous two months
bouncing around the Mediterranean like a
ship-based DVD screen saver and so on
the 1st of August he finally found the
French Fleet anchored 20 mi Northeast of
Alexandria the ensuing Skirmish was
every bit is one-sided as the battle of
the pyramids only this time it was the
French getting their asses handed to
them their fleet was almost entirely
destroyed leaving Napoleon's Army
trapped in Egypt since going home was no
longer an option Napoleon figured he
might as well do a bit more conquering
so he pushed East into ottoman held
Syria capturing several Coastal
settlements along the way but completely
cut off from France he had no means of
resupplying his army and the casualties
were mounting things got even worse when
an outbreak of Bubonic plague killed
hundreds of his soldiers and the French
army was eventually defeated after
trying and failing to capture the city
of
AA a good General knows when to retreat
and that's exactly what Napoleon did
next but without any ships there wasn't
anywhere to retreat to in the end he
left Egypt in secret sneaking away on a
small vessel in the middle of the night
his army didn't even know he'd gone dick
move Napoleon dick move oh and remember
those 200 scientist he brought along if
you're wondering what they were up to
while all of this nonsense was going on
they were busy making what is
universally regarded as one of the
greatest archaeological finds in history
whilst Shoring up the defenses of Fort
Julian on the West Bank of denial they
discovered a strange slab of rock
covered in ancient writing built right
into one of the walls known today as to
Rosetta Stone it would later prove to be
the key to deciphering ancient
hieroglyphics
giving birth to the field of egyptology
in the
process anyway Napoleon arrived back in
France in October 1799 to find the
entire country had gone to [__] in his
absence when the rest of Europe had
found out that the French special
scientific operation in Egypt was
actually a fully-fledged invasion they
decided to form another tag team kicking
off the war of the second
Coalition but this time with their best
General in Egypt making ottoman soldiers
beg for their mummies France was losing
badly public opinion was wavering and
the new French government was on the
verge of collapse one of Napoleon's
greatest strengths as a general was
taking advantage of the enemy's
weaknesses but it turns out he was just
as good at exploiting weaknesses on his
own side too on the 9th of November 1799
he gathered his closest allies and
overthrew the French government in audar
installing himself as first Consul and
ruler of
France the French Revolution was
officially over and rather than an all
powerful Monarch France now had an all
powerful Napoleon in charge instead and
his first order of business was to cross
that pesky second
Coalition whilst he'd been gallivanting
around Egypt the austrians had snuck
back into France's territory in Northern
Italy you might assume that now Napoleon
was the ruler of France he would leave
the dirty business of fighting to his
generals but no surprising absolutely
everyone including his own Men He
personally led a huge Army over the
Swiss Alps sneaking up on a
significantly larger Austrian force that
was besieging
genua from there things went pretty
predictably Napoleon won a string of
battles against the odds and two weeks
later the war of the second Coalition
was over this time even Britain agreed
to call it quits for the first time in
over 10 years Europe was at peace
spoiler alert it didn't last very long
with no enemy armies to embarrass for
the moment Napoleon had time to catch up
on a bit of admin back in Paris this was
the first chance for the French public
to see what the legendary General was
like at governing and it turned out he
was well
spectacular during his years in power
Napoleon complet completely
revolutionized almost every aspect of
French society he introduced a
Napoleonic Code which comprehensively
reformed and codified civil law across
the whole of France for the first time
he modernized the school system greatly
improving the number and quality of
schools he created the bank of France
and reworked the tax system to help the
nation recover from the economic tall of
the Revolution and he modernized Paris
almost beyond
recognition but before we call him the
greatest leader ever there was a darker
side to Napoleon's rule for one thing
most of the reforms he introduced only
benefited about half of the French
population the half with penises under
Napoleon women had many of the basic
rights they'd enjoyed under the monarchy
removed entirely then there was slavery
the French Revolution was founded on the
idea that all men were equal and one of
its major accomplishments was the
abolishment of slavery across the Empire
but Napoleon quietly introduced it in
the French Caribbean to help speed up
his plans for colonization in the new
world despite these major shortcomings
in the eyes of the French people well
half of them Napoleon could do no wrong
and apparently he agreed because in the
spring of 1802 he gave himself a little
promotion from first Consul to First
consul for Life peace in Europe also
gave Napoleon time to dabble in his new
side Hustle real estate and when I say
dabble I mean he sold over 800,000
square miles of land to the US in what
was and still is the single biggest real
estate deal in human history known today
as the Louisiana Purchase it roughly
doubled the size of the United States of
America and changed the course of world
history in the
process back in Europe tensions between
France and Britain were rising and in
1803 British decided to cut the foreplay
and declared war the war of the third
Coalition had begun although to begin
with that Coalition was made up of well
it was just Britain we really hated the
French back then by this point Napoleon
was either the greatest man alive or the
biggest [__] on the planet it mostly
depended on whether or not you were
French and whether you had a penis
either way there must have been quite a
lot of people in Camp [__] because
during Napolean Reign he survived at
least 30 assassination attempts and all
of those people trying to murder him got
him thinking what would happen to France
when he died conso for life was great
and all but Napoleon didn't want to just
be in charge as long as he lived he
wanted to rule forever and that meant it
was time for another promotion in
December 1804 in one of the most opulent
ceremonies ever witnessed Napoleon
bonapart crowned himself emper emperor
of
France the new job title didn't
necessarily increase his power that was
already absolute but it did mean he
could pass on his title to his sons when
he died his legacy was assur now fully
evolved into his Emperor end form nap
poemon bonapar started to play God aater
mul with the countries of Europe playing
the part of Team Rocket were coalition
three four and five and Napoleon
defeated them just as easily as he'd
beaten the first two to help fight what
were now continent spanning Wars
Napoleon essentially invented the
concept of mass conscription drawing
fresh troops from across the ever
expanding French Empire at its peak his
army contains some
600,000 men almost three times as many
soldiers as the British army at the time
such a large force was an absolute night
M to control in the days before the
radio so Napoleon came up with a
completely new way of organizing his
troops you're probably familiar with the
concept of military cause well it turns
out Napoleon invented that he split his
army up into individual mixed arms
subdivisions that functioned like mini
armies able to act independently as a
result Napoleon's giant army was
significantly faster and much more
flexible than any other which was
especially useful whenever he felt like
pulling off his signat Mortal Combat
finishing move the total envelopment of
the
enemy Europe was powerless against him
during his Reign he deleted the Holy
Roman Empire a dynasty that had St for
over a thousand years defeated the
powerful Austrian Empire no fewer than
four times and won countless battles
when outnumbered and outgunned often
suffering miraculously minor
casualties by 1812 the French Empire
spanned most of the continent and
Napoleon had installed multiple family
members on various Thrones around Europe
but there were two notable absentees
from his growing collection of countries
Great Britain and Russia in 1805
Napoleon's Nile Nemesis Nelson had nixed
a combined French and Spanish Fleet in
the Battle of
Trafalga and Napoleon had never managed
to rebuild it
that meant an invasion of Britain was
almost impossible now so he turned his
attention to Russia
instead on the 24th of June 1812 half a
million French soldiers marched into
Russia after more than a decade of
watching Napoleon kick the crap out of
anyone who dared to challenge him the
Russians had absolutely zero interest in
trying to defeat him in the field the
man was obviously Invincible instead
they executed a military maneuver that
most of Europe had plenty of practice at
by this point the out Retreat as they
fell back the Russians burned everything
that might have been used by the French
army from buildings to fields and key
infrastructure that put a huge strain on
Napoleon's supply lines which only
worsened the deeper into Russian
territory the French army
pushed it didn't help that conditions
were awful the summer of 1812 was
unusually hot and combined with the long
forced marches and the lack of food
Napoleon troops many of whom had been
conscripted from across the empire were
starting to
Desert as the Russian armies moonwalked
their way ever deeper into friendly
territory Napoleon's Army was weakening
by the time the Russians turns to fight
during the Battle of badino he was
outnumbered he won as always but this
time French losses were enormous still
the victory did allow Napoleon to occupy
Moscow meaning he done the impossible
and defeated Russia there was just one
problem nobody had told the
Russians Napoleon waited patiently for
his conquered foe to sue for peace but
they didn't in fact they didn't do
anything and the French Emperor was left
pottering around Moscow looking for odd
jobs that needed doing like a pensioner
trying to keep himself busy after
retirement as days turned into weeks he
slowly began to realize is he' made a
massive mistake his crippled Army was
over a thousand miles from home and in
the words of Ned Stark winter was coming
if he'd stayed in Moscow he'd be trapped
and so he did the only thing he could
Retreat unfortunately by that point
winter wasn't just coming it was already
bloody everywhere Napoleon had marched
into Russia at the height of Summer and
now in the midst of winter his men had
no Provisions for the Frid conditions of
the retreat tens of thousands died from
cold starvation or disease and tens of
thousands more were killed by Russian
raids of the half a million troops that
marched into Russia in June
1812 just
40,000 made it out
alive for the first time in more than a
decade the Invincible Napoleon bonapar
was weak knowing his enemies were
waiting to pound he rushed back to Paris
to raise another Army quickly Gathering
a force of over
350,000 men but they were mostly
rookies it's hard to keep track but by
this point Europe had coupled together
its sixth coalition to try and deal with
the Napoleon problem this time made up
of Prussia Russia Spain Portugal Sweden
the United Kingdom and several smaller
German states despite being vastly
outnumbered and commanding an
inexperienced Army Napoleon used all his
genius to score several major victories
against the
Allies but it wasn't enough with attacks
coming in on multiple fronts and much of
the French army in full Retreat Napoleon
was eventually defeated in the Battle of
leig he was eventually forced to
abdicate and Louis VI 18th brother of
the previous recently guillotined King
took the
[Music]
throne Napoleon was sent into Exile on
the island of ela off the coast of tusky
as a mark of respect or possibly just to
piss him off the Allies named him
emperor of his new
domain whatever the motivation Napoleon
took this role seriously introducing his
customary sweeping reforms in just nine
months he created a mini Army a Navy
invested in the Island's infrastructure
introduced modern agricultural methods
established an iron mine and updated
elba's legal and Educational Systems but
after having control most of Europe a
small island was never going to be
enough leading a micro Army of 700 men
he escaped Landing in France on the 1st
of March
[Music]
1815 even led by the legendary Napoleon
700 men should have posed zero threat to
France but the newly installed King made
a fatal error he sent a huge Army to
destroy Napoleon once and for all a huge
Army made up of soldiers who utterly
adored their former General the king's
Army promptly switched sides and began
marching on Paris apparently a bit of a
slow learner Louis VI 18th sent yet
another even bigger Army to take down
Napoleon and yeah that one defected as
well the king briefly considered sending
yet another Army then thought better of
it and fled to Belgium on the 20th of
March 1815 the and marched into Paris at
the head of his new Army the king had
[Music]
returned the rest of Europe responded to
this unwelcome news the only way they
knew how by forming yes another
Coalition we're on the seventh now by
the way just in case you're keeping
score Napoleon did his best to raise a
new Army but that simply wasn't the time
and that left him with two choices
either Turtle up an attempt to defend
France against the incoming coalition
invasions or go on the offensive as you
can probably guess he opted for the
latter hoping to score some trademark
quick victories and force the Allies to
sue for peace so that he could properly
rebuild it almost worked he led the bulk
of his Force North into what was then
the United Kingdom of the Netherlands
and is now Belgium where he found
himself heavily outnumbered by two
Coalition armies one British one
Prussian fighting both at the same time
would have been suicide so Napoleon
separated the armies by sending the bulk
of his forces between their positions
from there he was able to quickly defeat
the prussians but the British army
commanded by the Duke of Wellington puts
up Fierce resistance after taking a
defensive position near the town that
gave the battle its name waterl it gave
the beaten Prussian Army just enough
time to regroup and attack Napoleon's
right flank round housing the French
[Music]
AR after winning the first five
Coalition Wars Napoleon had now lost two
in a row and this time there would be no
sneaky comebacks the Allies had learned
from the mistake of sending him to
actually not all that far away Elba this
time they didn't take any chances the
French Emperor was exiled to St Helena
literally one of the most remote
inhabited Islands on planet Earth
Napoleon was lived there until his death
on the 5th of May 1821 at the age of 51
he was buried on the island but in 1840
his remains were returned to France and
they now rest beneath the Dome of the
magnificent leim valids in
Paris historians can't seem to agree on
how best to categorize the remarkable
life of Napoleon bonapart to some he was
a tyrant who betrayed the revolution
that made him to others he was a he hero
who changed the world mostly for the
better some view him as a power hungry
megalomaniac intent on Conquering the
world others believe he was simply
protecting French interests against
Relentless European aggression either
way his influence on the history of our
species cannot be
overstated after his death his many
reforms and Innovations across law
education economics and civil
Administration
were replicated all over the world some
of them remain in place even today and
something that's in no doubt whatsoever
is his almost Supernatural military
genius it's hard to sum up just how
remarkable Napoleon was so I'm not going
to even try instead I'll leave you with
the words of the man who finally
vanquished him in the years after
waterloop the Duke of Wellington was
asked to give his opinion on who was the
greatest general of the age his answer
answer was
simple in this age in past ages in any
age
Napoleon thanks for watching our history
has been pockmarked with Warfare and
unfortunately things haven't changed all
that much since the days of Napoleon
sadly it's often animals and are
beautiful natural environments that
become the victim of Humanity's
conflicts I support Planet wild because
they're actually putting into action
what many of us wish we could do but
don't have the resources to they carry
out a new rewilding Mission every month
they work with Wildlife Pioneers
worldwide to bring back endangered
species clean up our oceans and revive
forests and by supporting them you are
directly supporting these missions to
restore our planet's environments and
put things right I really love Planet
Wild's transparency they document their
work in monthly video reports on their
YouTube channel and they have app which
allows you to vote how you'd want your
funds to be used so you can actually see
the difference you're making on their
latest Mission Planet wild are planting
40,000 trees and learning more about
Forest Gardens a genius approach to tree
planting and a natural solution to
overcome desertification if you want to
join a growing Community making a real
difference protecting our ecosystems
check them out and consider becoming a
supporter the first 200 of my
subscribers to use the code 42 will get
their first month for free click the
link in the description below or just
use the QR code on screen right now also
make sure to check out Planet Wild's
channel right here on YouTube the link
for that is in the description too a big
thanks to Planet wild for sponsoring
this video and please don't forget to
check them out because what they're
doing is genuinely amazing